the Guardians of the Galaxy have taken
their last ride and the Marvel universe
may never be the same who lives who dies
and what's the deal with that talking
dog let's break down the ending of this
Trilogy capping Adventure warning
spoilers ahead for Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. most of Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is spent trying to save
rocket the movie opens with a brutal
attack by Adam Warlock on nowhere which
has become a thriving base of operations
for the guardian since they bought it
and their Disney plus holiday special
rocket is grievously injured in the
assault saving him means going after the
high evolutionary the deranged
bioengineer obsessed with creating the
perfect species and the perfect Society
he's also the man who made rocket what
he is making the whole mission more
complicated by the Final Act rocket is
healed but his creator still seeks
Vengeance what follows is a massive
space battle between nowhere and the
evolutionaries flagship while the
Guardians attempt to save the many
innocent beings trapped by the villain
what makes this climax really hit home
though is the character's willingness to
sacrifice they spent the whole film
trying to revive Rockets only for nebula
Drax and mantis to get captured in the
process so rocket Star-Lord and Gamora
go back for them the children The
evolutionary is imprisoned and every
other life form on a ship volume 3 is a
movie where saving lives not killing the
villain is the goal the ending resonates
much stronger for that reason baracket
fighting through the high evolutionaries
Flagship means returning to the place of
his creation we get his full backstory
in bits and pieces throughout the movie
his horrific caged existence is a baby
raccoon his brutal transformation into a
humanoid hybrid and his eventual Escape
we also see how his three closest
friends in captivity all died as they
tried to flee you think that going back
would be a tough ask for Rockets but he
does it without fear or hesitation I'm
done running he leads a charge into the
belly of the Beast and eventually he
works his way to the Very Room where he
and his friends were once caged the
cells are packed with more innocent
animal specimens and Rocket sets them
all free his encounter with a cage of
baby raccoons is particularly powerful
desperate to give them the chance he
never had he struggles to fit every
single one on his body and carry them to
safety in a stark contrast as the
previous films rocket even acknowledges
himself as a raccoon in the scene after
reading the label on the cage what's a
raccoon it's what you are stupid ain't
no thing like me except me having faced
his demons and conquered them he's
finally able to take ownership of who he
truly is free of anyone else's control
at last just like the animals he
liberates he's free Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is all about creation it's
a thing the high evolutionary is
obsessed with building a species in
society that's perfect but his Ambitions
are so thoroughly corrupted that all his
efforts turn out wrong he didn't want to
make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
after defeating the villain the
Guardians take a different approach to
Creation nowhere more than doubles in
population size thanks to all the freed
life forms and nebula dedicates herself
to building a new Society for them she
uses the same words as high evolutionary
yet the society she refers to couldn't
be more different where the villain used
Eugenics to eradicate any traits he
deemed unsuitable nowhere welcomes all
kinds of people and become a home around
them it's powerful to see nebula so
dedicated to creating something good for
years rage was her only motivator and
violence her only tool now she genuinely
wants to be the one in charge the person
responsible for building a better world
and protecting those in it fortunately
she'll have Drax by her side while she
does it after insulting him mercilessly
for most of the movie She acknowledges
his pure heart and asks for his help
with the children Gamora is dead Long
Live Gamora for most in the movie Peter
tries desperately to bring the New or
Old depending on how you view the
Guardians of the Galaxy timeline Gamora
back to the version new but by the end
of Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 she's
still not there and she may never be
Gamora certainly has an arc in the movie
at the start she's a cold-hearted loner
with no interest in rebuilding
friendships with any of the Guardians
but as the Adventure Continues she
starts to soften and seems to enjoy
being around them she can even
understand Groot Again by the end of the
film however she doesn't actually rejoin
the family instead she decides to return
to the ravagers where she seems to
genuinely belong as she she's simply not
the person he used to know and it's
unlikely that she will ever be there's
still a moment of hesitation before she
leaves Peter for good looking away from
him both tearing up she says simply I
bet we were fun it's an effective line
an acknowledgment that she both wishes
she could be that person again and that
she can't she can only be the Gamora she
is now one who seems happily at home
with her new ravager family having only
joined the franchise and Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 2 mantis has always felt
a bit like a secondary protagonist vol 3
fixes out by giving her as much material
as nearly anyone else in the movie and
it acknowledges her own unique role by
sending her off on some solo Adventures
at the end of the movie a high
evolutionary is defeated nowhere is
saved and the Guardians all choose
different paths for the immediate future
romantis that means following her own
compass for once rather than egos or her
teams or anyone else's what does that
mean exactly maybe setting up her own
private practice where she helps people
process their emotions maybe a long
relaxing well-earned vacation at the
cushiest resorts in the Galaxy or maybe
she'll continue her superhero War just
outside the purview of the other
Guardians what a romantic his next
chapter brings it could Slaughter back
into the MCU at a later point for now
though she's clearly focused on herself
which is a healthy departure from the
character we met in volume 2. both of
ego's children in the Guardians take
some solo time at the end of volume 3.
mantis goes off to focus on her own
desires and priorities and Star-Lord
finally Ventures home to Earth as he
tells the rest of crew he's been running
ever since his mother died when he was a
kid so in the interest of no longer
running he goes to see if his
grandfather is still alive lo and behold
he is Peter Quill's reunion with his
aging grandpa is a touching moment it's
sweet to see the family back together at
last but it also symbolizes a major step
in Peter's larger Arc but he says to his
team is right he's been running his
whole life whether that's from his own
problems enemy ravagers the law or
Thanos he's always managed to find some
crisis to keep him busy and his mind off
of more personal matters his willingness
to face his past at all to cast off the
markers of Star-Lord and just become
Pete for a while is commendable it shows
just how far he's come over the course
of the trilogy and the MCU as a whole at
the end of the day the Guardians of the
Galaxy films are about accepting the bad
things that have happened to you and
finding new sources of joy in spite of
them that process is never easy but
Peter's finally on the right path
[Music]
it's maybe the most famous line in all
of the MCU strictly on the merits of how
frequently it's been said when a major
character can only say one thing it's
bound to pop up a lot but at the end of
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 something
strange happens in their final meeting
before going their separate ways the
Guardians hug it out and Groot says
something different I love you guys if
you're a bit confused while watching the
scene that's more than fair after all
the other characters don't even react
but that's because Groot doesn't
actually say anything different than
normal all of us can just understand it
now in a 2020 interview with Digital Spy
James Gunn explained how groot's
language actually works people don't
learn group through knowing the language
they learn it through connecting with
Groot the film demonstrates this just
moments before the big line in the scene
between the big guy and Gamora he
approaches her alone to tell her it was
good to work with her again and she's
surprised to discover that she
understands him by going on the Grand
Adventure to save rockets and defeat the
high evolutionary she's reconnected with
Groot enough to speak with him and so if
we this is a true fourth wall break
moment because we've all followed the
Guardians on their any Adventures we too
can finally understand root we all the
film seems to say are part of the family
Redemption is one of the big themes of
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. in the
Final Act Adam Warlock is baffled after
Groot saves him from certain death his
confusion is understandable after all he
spends a whole movie trying to kill the
Guardians the group gives a simple
answer and Drax translate saying
everyone deserves a second chance Adam
quickly justifies this by Saving
Star-Lord from the cold vacuum of space
however he's far from the only character
in the movie to benefit from a second
chance nebula has arguably the most
significant art through the whole
Guardian series for the end of volume 3
seeing her heading up a new healthy
positive Society it's a far cry from the
violent villain she is in the first film
and shows just how far A little
compassion and kindness can go Peter
also gives his grandfather a second
chance after a rocky childhood and it
ends up being the right decision
Guardians of the Galaxy has always been
about healing about how trauma changes
us but also how we can grow past it
volume 3 takes that theme to its natural
conclusion by telling a story all about
the film opens with a rocket flashback
followed by a long take tour of nowhere
under construction with nebula leading
the effort the citizens of the cosmic
Community are building something
together and after Adam Warlock comes in
and smashes half of nowhere to bids they
start rebuilding Peter rebuilds his life
after the death of Gamora rocket
rebuilds his after a lifetime of abuse
even Drax finds a kind of surrogate
family by becoming an adopted father to
the many child prisoners of the high
evolutionary from every angle Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 shows that tragedy
leaves scars with a healing and
rebuilding are always possible
characters and Guardians are broken
people at the start hurt by loneliness
torture and loss but by the end of
volume 3 they've made a home for
themselves and others like them were all
or welcome this all stands in stark
contrast to the high evolutionary who
would rather demolish an entire planet
he created and start over than attempt
to fix things his view that flaws are to
be incinerated not treated is the reason
he becomes so corrupt Perfection that's
what the high evolutionary claims to be
pursuing my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society for the
good of the Galaxy he says he must
create destroy and torment countless
lives all to make something perfect but
of course there's no such thing as a
perfect species or a perfect world or a
perfect person everything in Guardians
of the Galaxy is broken but that's what
makes it beautiful Rockets suffered
horribly at the hands of the high
evolutionary and lost close friends but
he still manages to find a new family
for himself just like Peter Drax and the
others do Gamora is a walking ghost in
volume 3. a woman whose life was stolen
from her and who's forced to pick up the
pieces and yet she finds a new path that
still gives her meaning nebula is
perhaps the clearest example of this
theme as her body was literally broken
Time and Again by her father but now she
uses those modifications to help others
it's only fitting then that the
Guardians builds their home on nowhere
the severed head of an ancient being
that's been attacked and reconstructed
numerous times and of course there's
rocket himself who finds the flaw in his
Creator's bioengineering scheme despite
being by all accounts a run-of-the-mill
experiment there's no such thing as a
perfect world but there is power and
purpose in Perfection for the high
evolutionary sees flaws in his Creations
citizens of nowhere see valuable life
the superhero genre has gotten so
expensive and complicated in recent
years that it can be easy to forget its
original appeal long before endless
Easter eggs and multiversal crossovers
comic book movies were about Superman
and Batman saving innocent people didn't
have to be from Lex Luthor or the Joker
or Thanos sometimes it was just from a
burning building or an airplane that
lost an engine or a runaway train
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 gets back
to that original superhero intention in
its final Act it's not enough for the
heroes to say just themselves or the
children imprisoned by the high
evolutionary they have to save everyone
from the biggest abolisk to the smallest
baby raccoon it seems like an obvious
beat for a Marvel movie and yet it feels
surprisingly fresh instead of putting
the climactic focus on beating the bad
guy James Gunn rests it squarely on the
rescue the saving of lives the scene
where all the animals Escape is honestly
pretty emotional as well as being
hilarious the message of Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 seems to be that all
life regard regardless of creation
intention or language is sacred he left
out some important information but
that is the gist of it as is only
appropriate for the third film in the
series Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
ends with an extended dance scene set to
a famous pop song but thanks to the Zune
passed down from yondu to Star-Lord to
Rocket it's a lot more modern than most
of the music in the franchise rocket
hooks the audio up to speakers all
around nowhere and starts blasting
Florence in the machine's 2008 hit Dog
Days Are Over it's the perfect choice
the song provides a beautiful thematic
wrap up to the whole Guardians Trilogy
it describes a woman who runs and hides
from happiness terrified of losing it
she knows the pain and sadness of the
past and fear is facing them again but
she must Embrace The Joy despite her
fear despite her vulnerability to Future
hurts living in fear is no way to live
if you watch these movies that message
shouldn't need much contextualizing all
of the Guardians have been running from
things since we met them personal losses
regrets traumatic childhoods name it and
they're all scared to trust again
because it could mean more betrayal down
the line fortunately they convince one
another to step back into the space of
Hope every Marvel movie has to have a
mid credit and in Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 it shows us The Fate to the
team after its many notable departures
rocket is now leading the show with a
supporting crew made up of groot's
cragling Cosmo the space dog Adam
Warlock and a young girl rescued from
the high evolutionary named Phila who
could be the comic spy Lavelle we catch
up with the updated troop as they fight
off a herd of deadly monsters on a
desert planet kraglan has fully mastered
yandu's yaka Arrow by this point and
Groot has grown to a truly gargantuan
size as they all await the arrival of
their foes rocket asks everyone what
their current go-to song is they all
share and when he's asked the same
question in return rocket puts on
something special red bones come and get
your love which kicked off the first
Guardians film it's a great choice not
just because it brings the trilogy full
circle but because it shows the legacy
of guardian's Captain passed down from
Star-Lord to Rocket the scene also
drives home just how much happier and
healthier rocket is now having
rediscovered and fully embraced his
childhood Love Of Music the Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 post-credits scene
shows Peter Quill eating a peaceful
breakfast of cereal with his grandfather
who's reading it newspaper they chat
briefly and when the scene Fades to
Black a message appears stating that
Star-Lord will return to the MCU this is
pretty big news as all indications from
James Gunn and the cast point to Volume
3 being the end of the story it's
significant that the Stinger only
mentions Star-Lord rather than the whole
team as that implies that the Guardians
of the Galaxy Squad is done at least for
now so when will we see Peter Quill
again that's a good question the logical
explanation is that Star-Lord will pop
up on Earth in some future MCU project
possibly Secret Wars the Marvels or
Avengers the Kang Dynasty Disney would
need to have such an appearance lockdown
of Chris Pratt already in order to make
that commitment and it's easy to imagine
him helping out some of his fellow
earthlings down the line does that mean
that the other Guardians couldn't also
return someday not necessarily James
Gunn is likely done with Marvel for the
foreseeable future now that he's heading
up DC's docket of superhero films but
some of his characters could come back
in cameos or crossovers however
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 feels like
a pretty clear finale for this
particular Squad it's the end of an era
and the first real Trilogy Marvel
Studios has completed in years every
character gets to walk into the sunset
in their own way and the series might do
well to leave them there for a while